happens just comes at you e3 match comes
at you from nowhere hello welcome back
to game spots continuing coverage of e3
2014 my name is daniel dwyer uh and
we're here super smash brothers brawl
i'm going to say this straight away if
you have any questions get them on
twitter at daniella right now because i
bet
corey here is going to have a lot of
stuff to ask answer for corey pleasure
to see you sir you guys had a tournament
yesterday yeah were you there thank you
uh first of all yeah thank you for
having us um we did have a tournament
for super smash brothers for wii u
yesterday i got to uh you know get away
from here for about uh what would i say
like maybe a half hour to check it out
okay it was awesome i saw a big old
crowd of people the energy in that uh
nokia theater was absolutely phenomenal
uh what was the emphasis of that was it
primarily as they just
let
players get their hands on it or were
you like taking feedback from people on
character level balancing or well a lot
of it was just a celebration of the fans
you know we invited uh you know 16 of
the most talented uh super smash
brothers players from around the world
um and really got to see how these
competitive players uh you know got
getting their hands on the new game for
the very first time and even seeing them
uh you know play as new characters we
had mega man we had um did you hear
pac-man
pac-man of course as a lot of fans
noticed last night was announced as a
new playable character and how rad is it
that we now have pac-man mega man sonic
and mario all finally the old crew is
back together it's like a buddy comedy
except everyone beats the crap out of
each other like if you would have told
me that that was a possibility when i
was a kid like i would have needed new
pants like
and super smash brothers uh is also
available for folks in north america
right now to play is that right so yeah
um we are actually doing a special event
partnering with best buy so uh today
actually wednesday if you go to uh a
certain best buys we've got over 100
locations in north america you can go to
e3.nintendo.com to check out check it
out but from four to nine we've got
super smash brothers uh for wii u
playable i believe we've got the
nintendo 3ds version there for folks
that actually pre-order the game you're
going to receive a uh
a special gold coin as well it's
collector's gold coin uh if you don't if
you're not able to make it out today
we're also going to be doing the event
on saturday as well so a really cool
event for fans that can't be here at e3
you can still have an opportunity to get
your hands on sweet um i want to talk a
little about the gameplay of super smash
bros i'll put my hand on heart i'm not a
massive player i've a bunch of friends
who are huge fans of it and i've watched
a lot of them play and what i remember a
lot of was the melee the gamecube
version we used to play a lot of and
that seems to be um i was at an event in
san francisco last week but it was a big
super smash bros tournament on right and
that seemed to be still what people are
playing brawl never really sort of
broke in there with with that crowd and
a lot of people say it's because there
was an element of randomness or luck to
the to the to the fighting it seems like
you guys are
tightening up on that stuff making it
more like melee yeah one thing that uh
you know we announced in a super smash
brothers nintendo direct actually is mr
sakurai has uh he's allowed he's
basically broken the online down into
like for glory and for fun so if you're
the type of player that wants to play
with no items and on a final destination
type map you're going to be able to do
that um but if you just want to go
online you know the smash brothers
series is great because it does appeal
to you know the casual nintendo fans but
the most hardcore as well so both both
kind of uh
uh groups will be able to find a lot of
uh fun to be yeah do you have any like
specifics on that sort of stuff i know
like sort of like the infinite punching
stuff has been rounded off like combos
seem to end and they get pushed apart
and whatnot it's you know it's all gonna
depend on the character right now we're
still playing a lot with the uh the
characters learning the characters even
internally but uh you know we're
definitely trying our best to uh
every character is gonna have a
different feel but uh we certainly don't
want one character to just be like oh my
gosh like everyone's gonna be fox on
final destination you know something
like that how's pac-man gonna work he
hasn't even got legs
we're using the version of pac-man from
uh pac-land so
it's his final smash that he actually
turns 2d the family favorite
person we actually did bring by the uh
both versions if we want to see a little
bit of gameplay from the nintendo 3ds
version we got some gameplay let's throw
it up so uh one thing we wanted to talk
about the nintendo 3ds version is it's
got a
game mode specific to it called smash
run
not available in the wii u version
and this mode basically uh you're gonna
have five minutes to run through this
giant labyrinth uh powering up your
character boosting your stats like speed
jumping
um
and it's one of the cool things is if
you ended up choosing a slower character
like bowser you could collect speed
throughout the uh the smash run and it's
going to culminate uh this mode after
five minutes of playing in this final
battle so all of these stat boosts will
then
uh take into account so here we actually
chose uh greninja one of the brand new
playable characters you may know from
pokemon x pokemon y kind of the final
evolution
of uh frookie
beating up on some koopas here yeah and
this is uh what we're seeing is again uh
the objective you see the timer in the
upper right there's no
right or wrong way to go you're just
trying to move as quickly as possible
beating up baddies you're you're seeing
a few of those collectible uh
um basically boosts that she's getting
or that we're getting here and on the
bottom screen you can just see how large
this map is in smash run you can see
where some of our opponents are of
course we're playing cpus but when the
game comes out you'll be able to play uh
um
with other friends dude are you just
trying to accrue as many of those
power-ups as possible exactly that is
really the only objective here um we've
kind of gone back to the uh other screen
now where you're able to see on the
bottom screen some of these
uh equippable items
so all those six icons there we can tap
on the touch screen to perform an action
you've got like a meteor shower which
would bring down the fire on your
enemies right here um and for me i like
to use these as quickly as possible
because you
you're uh you're gonna boost up your
character quicker and those stats will
automatically go to your character and
you're not able to take these items into
the final battle yeah um as you play the
game um continue to play the game you're
going to be unlocking more equippable
items so you can actually customize that
loadout to your liking i like it it's
almost like the start of a dota match
when you're like setting up your you're
like farming for resources and setting
up your character exactly and then it
all ends in one big battle if we've got
some uh gameplay of the the wii u
version that'll be amazing because we've
got some uh we've got a lot of questions
i'm gonna get i'm gonna i'm gonna get
these out of the way corey okay because
i'm sure people are gonna ask you this
stuff all the time sure characters
donkey kong donkey kong in it donkey
kong we've got dk dk's in it all right
solid snake
um we have not announced uh
okay that's in the question mark area no
problem what happens when kirby eats
pac-man asks oh that's a good question
i'm curious to know that we did unveil
him last night there's a trailer out
there but i don't think we saw kirby
inhale pac-man
uh let's uh i want to talk to you about
the controller as well that's recently
been announced that must be a real get
for you because a lot of people still
love playing um smash bros frozone if
they had a chat if they had the option
would would probably go for i have thank
you such fond memories of playing um not
only do i have fond memories of playing
super smash brothers melee but yeah
we're still playing it internally uh at
you know nintendo so to be able to still
you know use that controller it still
feels great it almost like melts in my
hands um but it's really great we're
gonna be of course um selling that when
that when that comes out with the
gamecube adapter excellent i will yeah
do you think you're gonna do it as a
bundle um no announcements on that yet
but you know you never know cool i want
to talk a little bit about the character
customization stuff as well it just
seems pretty interesting you like you
can pick a character but then perhaps
give them traits without with items that
they might not necessarily have yeah so
uh you know you'll be able to uh certain
characters um will have you know mario
might have three
fireballs he might have the regular
fireball he throws and like a super
fireball you can actually choose and
customize which moveset you want him to
use okay um
but if you were then playing online um
you would you might be like constricted
to that normal right yeah that makes
sense
uh it looks like we got about one more
minute in the smash run here but one
thing i did want to point out was that
we got into a challenge room earlier so
each time you're playing smash run you
are going to uh it's going to be
completely random the enemy placements
are random these challenge rooms are
random and uh you know you might have
some sort of challenge like uh there we
were uh previously we were breaking this
like icicle apart yeah um
here they've got like this giant enemy
unfortunately we've used up all of our
like power bombs and meteor showers so
that thing looks messed up what is that
i he looks like an enemy from uh kid
icarus uprising is that is that the
level we're in at the moment as well i'm
assuming a lot of these these arenas are
also based are they based specifically
on smash brothers
maps or on just the tile set so this is
a just a map that's just unique to super
smash brothers for nintendo 3ds and it's
one giant map but as we saw earlier when
we checked it out like there's all these
different parts of the map there's no
way you're going to be able to explore
the entire thing in one go yeah so if
you were a character like kirby you
might want to like
have easier access to higher areas but
there are also random events that take
place that you'll see like a news flash
come upon the bottom screen it'll say
like there's a uh a big boss that you
can fight in the lower area and then you
can either choose to go there or
not and if you did go take that boss on
you beat them you would get a lot of
power-ups
now here we've got a few seconds left
we're gonna see our results screen so
you can see on the bottom already some
of our boosts but uh these are all of
the stats we got speed and special
particularly we did well in excellent so
uh greninja is already a fast character
we are going to be ridiculously fast now
and is this is this a
is this one round or
this is still part of the same smash run
yeah but it is this final battle yeah
it's single elimination all right and
it's always a random uh rule set as well
right now we're playing traditional
smash rules which is just as many kos as
possible but some of the rules will
change on you like you might get a smash
uh a battle that ends with like
everybody has reflectors on them so
things bounce off of everybody or
everyone is like super mushrooms so
really giant
we are playing the course rainbow road
for mario kart 7. and one thing to
mention about that as well the nintendo
3ds version does feature stages
from the portable systems so
um you know you'll be seeing levels like
uh based off of like nintendogs plus
cats or
um the legend of zelda spirit tracks for
example
i love the shy guys here that come
through as well
all right who's going to win calling it
i'm going to guess the player is going
to win
for us i'm pulling for greninja little
mac is really fun too of course uh
you're seeing little mac above his
character he's got this special ko meter
that if you fill up he gets a special ko
opportunity
time up
it's so i like it you guys are i guess a
problem with any sort of series that has
this much fun in mind is that you either
sort of try and placate the fans as much
as possible but then if you do that you
might do it at the detriment of new
people are trying to get into it this
seems like a mode that might help
especially portables which tend to have
a lot of younger players on them yeah i
might have them get into it and you can
take super smash brothers anywhere you
go oh man which is amazing the bathroom
confirmed
bathroom swimming pool
just be careful the water
just wanna i want to get all the i want
to get all the headlines here all right
great
cause this bathroom upstairs is awful
we're gonna eat three bathrooms no good
maybe that's why maybe because
everyone's they've all got early access
to smash brothers sitting there on our
asses doing it i've got a bunch of
questions coming in first of all though
i want to ask about the amiibo stuff yes
so nintendo announced they're entering
the sort of toys to life um um genre or
whatever you want to call it this idea
of what we've seen with skylanders and
disney infinity before as well right and
so
you guys are seem to be pretty well tied
into what they want to do with with
amiibo you just talk a little bit about
that for folks who might have seen it
yeah so if you uh kind of miss the
announcement uh amiibo are the
characters that we're going the figures
that we're going to be releasing at the
same time as uh super smash brothers for
wii u now these figures of course will
have like mario we're gonna have a lot
of different characters um
and we'll have uh figures for other
franchises and games
um they'll also work with other games
but with super smash brothers for wii u
um these characters or these figures
will allow you to basically
um
you'll be able to level up with these
characters so say i bought a mario
amiibo i could have my
amiibo character place him on the
gamepad screen i could have him fight
you as a human player excellent and
you're taking you're fighting against
mine let's say you like to dodge all the
time like or you know put up your shield
and it's really annoying um my character
the amiibo character can actually learn
by playing you and you always like match
after match it's like oh yeah like
really likes too danny really likes to
use the shield he's learning and so the
more he plays you he's gonna start to
try to grab you more and throw you um
you'll also be able to level those
characters up the level of your amiibos
up up to level 50. okay um and each one
is going to be very different so um
we're really really excited about these
coming out um we've announced uh we
haven't announced the final lineup of
the characters yeah presumably it won't
be every single character that's in
smash brothers yeah i don't know the
exact list i know that uh you know mr
sakurai joked yesterday of course the
director of the game that uh
he advised everyone you may want to
collect your favorite characters but uh
he himself is going to get them all and
i'll probably get them all as well maybe
just deduct them out of my paycheck
do you expect any sort of um cross play
between other franchises because
obviously amiibo is not something that's
just unique to smash bros do you think
that amiibos for other games perhaps
there might be some you know in the
future some say some interconnectivity
with smash brothers for the wii u we've
announced that amiibo uh figures will
also be compatible with mario kart 8 uh
captain toad treasure tracker which the
game we just announced
um there's a few other games that we've
announced it's compatibility with as
well so we look forward to sharing a lot
more details soon cool and let's have a
look we're looking at the wii u version
here as well just talk us through what's
going on here
you know what actually talk this through
for somebody who has never seen smash
bros before because i know there's at
least a handful of people who've never
seen it before yeah so
yeah the basic rules of super smash
brothers are pretty simple you want to
knock your opponent out as many times as
possible off the platform and all of
those percentages that you see down
there
everybody starts out with zero as you
pummel people that percentage goes
higher your hits start making people fly
further
so it's definitely not your traditional
uh fighting game at all more of this uh
you know character action party style
game
and the controls themselves are really
simple to get into you've just got the
jump button uh you've got two attack
buttons so anybody can uh can jump right
in and start having some success
immediately but it does have of course
that depth that you know hardcore
tournament players can really enjoy
i still haven't mastered melee and i've
been playing it for
god knows how long right and when you
when you're designing ai for those
individual characters as well because
like in traditional uh fighting games
you tend to
know at different levels of difficulty
how a character is going to act their
their character themselves is also how
they tend to fight um smash brothers for
me is a game that has always been about
multiplayer so when you're playing
pikachu you're never really playing
pikachu you're playing somebody who's
playing ass pikachu so when you're
making the ai the computer characters
for those characters
are you guys do you try and make it so
that pikachu
fights a certain way so that players
learn how to fight against him that way
or do you try and create it random so
perhaps
ai will play pikachu one way in one game
and then in a different game we'll use
him differently are you saying like in
different uh super smash brothers games
like in brawl specifically in this like
from game to game does pikachu
similarly gotcha um
match to match rather yeah there is you
know the customization options in this
game are absolutely ridiculous uh partly
because mr sakurai loves to give players
as many options as possible that said
before matches start you're able to
choose things like difficulty uh you
know i think we've got like level one to
nine at least um to choose so depending
on what difficulty you choose they might
use a little bit more move you know one
move or the other yeah um
but in general you never know exactly
what pikachu is going to do he's not
necessarily always going to use his
downbeat
lightning attack for example
i got some more questions coming in
joshua or kelly's asking um obviously
this is a a game that will have a legacy
this isn't a flash in the pan people
will most likely or at least you guys
hope will be playing this game for
months and years to come and
in terms of patches and post release uh
just ensuring that sort of everything's
working properly addressing balancing
issues that the community might have are
you guys preparing to be doing that sort
of stuff um i don't think there's been
any discussion really about that yet but
uh you know that being said we've got uh
to give one example pikmin three right
came out last august and just last week
we announced a brand new patch that
added a new control scheme so players
that haven't played pikmin 3 or maybe
even have are now able to play the game
off tv with touchscreen controls using
the stylus only so uh you know we
definitely have the ability to go in and
add features and things like that and
then what about adding to the game via
either free content or
paid for dlc are you going to do some of
that in the legacy of it um you know
nothing to announce at this time but
certainly that is something that uh i'm
sure could be could be a possibility
yeah i'm sure the internet will probably
tell you what type of characters they
want to have in it uh how close are you
guys away from release at this stage
we've got uh the two titles right we've
got super smash brothers for 3ds and
super smash brothers for wii u uh we're
going to be launching the nintendo 3ds
version first on october 3rd all right
not too far away and then we've got the
wii u version launching just after uh in
the hall in time for the holidays
and so uh we're definitely uh you're
going to be able to uh mr sakurai again
announced that you will be able to kind
of move characters from one to the other
so there is going to be that some
functionality where you're going to be
able to maybe be practicing on the
nintendo 3ds version maybe building some
characters up and somehow having some
interactivity yeah and then taking them
around with your amiibo into your body's
house or something exactly and the wii u
obviously has had a little bit of a
tower a little bit it's had a tower time
at retail uh perhaps not as doing as
well as as
nintendo might like and some nintendo
fans might like as well um is that a
concern with you guys or do you think
the folks who are into super smash
brothers have already got one or do you
think perhaps this is what will this
will actually help sell more consoles
you know i definitely have a lot of
friends who are ridiculously excited for
uh for mario kart 8 which just launched
and they uh if they hadn't had one they
just picked one up so we certainly know
that uh mario kart 8 and super smash
brothers um are huge huge titles for us
um but with the addition of upcoming
games like hyrule warriors coming in
september um bayonetta 2 coming soon
coming very soon as well that we're
going to have if you don't have a wii u
yet
this year is a great i mean right now is
a great time to buy one even with mario
kart 8 i know a lot of folks have picked
one up because there's a
free software deal if you buy mario kart
8 register it on club nintendo you can
get a free digital download of one of
four games oh excellent um
and so the invitational was on yesterday
and i think it was just over in l.a live
is that right uh that's correct yep um
this is one of the most enduring
communities in nintendo's history uh
which is some might find surprising
considering this game i remember when i
first saw it all those years back it
almost looked like a throwaway like this
is just some sort of crazy party game
let's let's see what happens um have you
guys ever like do you have much of a
hold on that community in terms of
setting up events yourself uh when you
look at games like you know
the modern day
fighting game community for instance is
like event spaces there are massive when
you look at stuff like
in international and whatnot like how
much of a hold on the
super smash brothers community do
nintendo have and is it something that
you guys are looking into maybe
participating in more directly yeah
that's a really good question and as you
mentioned you know going back to super
smash brothers brawl even melee it's not
a space we've been traditionally in so
with the uh
tournament that we did yesterday i'm
sure we're really going to look at that
i already you know it's
just being there last night you know
it's already it's like it was so
exciting to be a part of that even just
as an as an attendee at the back uh you
tend to get that much cosplay as
i saw a lot of cosplay happen you know
the one thing i love even me i've
actually
dressed as a nintendo character before
believe it or not
um
i did a half-life 2 zombie one so
i was once a blue pikmin um nice um but
uh great the one thing i love um our
fans you know me included are just very
passionate about our franchises so
it's always just puts a smile on my face
whenever i see someone you know dressed
as nests dressed as even mega man
yesterday we had people out there with
like pac-man signs they wanted to see
pac-man in the game and we finally uh
finally finally can announce it so how
important is it to you guys that this
becomes the game of choice for
the smash brothers fighting game
community
um
it's a good question that's another good
question you know in uh yesterday's
round table mr sakurai was uh he made a
small comment that he would really like
you know it's kind of one of his
personal
goals to make this one of the greatest
character
uh games of all time where you're
bringing in all of these iconic
characters together so you know with the
announcement of pac-man again it kind of
i'm super pumped yeah are you guys guys
gonna be i'm assuming like dripping new
characters out there the whole way up to
release i think it's safe to say that we
have not seen the whole roster yet how
many have you went in so far
i believe yesterday when i was looking
at the roster on screen there were 33
that we had announced okay so far and
that's you know it's kind of misleading
because we had me characters taking up
one tile but me characters actually
represents three different play styles
because you've got like the brawler uh
you've got the sword fighter and you've
got the uh the gunner and then you've
got like 36 customizable moves in
between the me characters so
um yeah yeah there's
already a ton a ton of characters why is
there a soccer ball happening in this
level soccer ball is a great item
football for those of our european union
sorry sorry
there are a lot of fun items in the game
you know you've got items like the
hammer which we saw a second ago from
the original donkey kong it's been in
all of these smash brothers games you've
got new items you've got the final smash
balls as well or the you know smash
balls
star what are they starlet star
god it's been a while something except
star wand there there you go
got that crate it's not a snake in that
crate
has it got our there's definitely
something fun inside that crate
you never know though right so i'm the
type of person that always goes for the
crate probably why i'm not like maybe
the best smash player because i'm just
always easily distracted by shiny
objects i'm like ooh what is this the
allure of the crate
love the assist trophies that we're
seeing down there at the bottom
in terms of the stages obviously
a lot of fighting games the stages are
it's just mere trimming it's it's an
atmosphere change uh smash brothers they
are intrinsic to the competitiveness of
every single uh game uh how many stages
do you guys have in this how are you
deep diving on uh returning favorites
are you making a lot of news though you
know there's uh in terms of like
returning favorites you've got things
like battlefield you're gonna have
things like final destination absolutely
but uh
we love adding you know maybe new stages
based off of franchises that we know
like there's this is of course based off
coliseum from fire emblem there is a new
super mario bros u course where
magikoopa comes in and is dynamically
changing the environment every few
minutes um
and again going back to the differences
between the nintendo 3ds version a lot
of the
um stages in this game are going to be
based off of console games versus the
portable stages in the nintendo 3ds game
excellent corey i think that's about as
much time as we have here super smash
brothers coming in on the wii u and 3ds
for the folks at home can you just let
them know again when those dates are so
uh for the
uh wii u version we've got holiday
nintendo 3ds uh october 3rd and if you
want to get your hands on it today check
out
bestbuye3.nintendo.com and saturday as
well will be there awesome corey thanks
very much coming on gamespot stage
really appreciate it samsung stage
continues we've got assassin's creed
unity up next so stick around